and you got to do an inventory of the
stories you tell cuz we tell stories
anthem we forget where we heard them and
their crew yeah they're probably not
yeah there's like a guy in my
neighborhood ski we call him Showtime
and he tells [ __ ] wild stories and
like yeah and then I was telling this
story once to my dad and you know he
this guy was telling the story the
neighbor for 10 years and I'm like yeah
Showtime said one time he punched a hole
in a wall and he behind the wall to
[ __ ] Mickey Mantle rookie card
and he pulled down ESA as a Mickey
Mantle hooker Mickey Mantle rookie card
and I was like that's not true I was
like no he punched a hole in the wall
there was a Mickey Mantle rookie card
behind it he's like no it's not true why
would you ever stories your dad told you
I think it stories my dad's own when I
was younger has now more I'm like oh he
was full of [ __ ] they're stories my dad
told me that it would definitely live
but then my mother who does not lie and
some of the stories she tells me about
my dad I'm like what cuz my dad was nuts
he was like a criminal alive he's alive
he's alive but he was like a [ __ ]
he's my dad Hispanic guy my dad is
old-school guy you know like Bronx guy
organized crime type [ __ ] you know in
and out of jail when I was a kid you
know and he's 75 years old now he's
diabetic you know [ __ ] he almost died
actually the day after Christmas guy ate
half of tray of lasagna like four
cannolis eleven three cups of coffee to
any vodka and then you know I'm just
watching me but then I'm like I got a
step in him like dad what are you doing
it goes all right you know I had a gay
son I'm like okay and then [ __ ] - three
hours later in the ER - means gargle and
I'm like who sounds gay now just a park
dog yeah I swear to God but my dad used
to tell me stories I'm like no way but
there's one story and my mom confirmed
it so my mom my dad is not a great
looking guy I mean y'all yeah so you
know and my mother's a beautiful woman
she went to an Ivy League school and you
know they met at a walkathon and my mom
was walking the walkathon raising money
for like a great cause and my dad was
doing community service on the side of
the walkathon prison work-release and
they wanted to she want to have like a
fling with the bad boy and they had me
so my mom's kind of stuck with this guy
now and they were at Central Park
my mother's 21 years old when she had me
so a central porno was you dead my dad
my mother was 21 with Jenn and my dad
was 38 so my dad yeah it's an older kid
so so they were laying down in Central
Park and my mom was like seven months
pregnant she had like a blanket over her
and my dad in the middle of the [ __ ]
day gets up to take a piss behind a tree
in the middle of Central Park so he's my
mom's just sitting there like reading a
book and dan Aykroyd was rollerblading
by a roller skating by and and he
started hitting on my mother my dad
chased dan Aykroyd like down a lane at
Central Park with a [ __ ] twit yeah
with his piss it's the height of Fame my
mom was like no that's like well [ __ ]
it's true yeah yeah this guy did your
dad hasn't beat the [ __ ] I don't know no
you skated away in Florida I'm sitting
at the game we're in the upper upper
upper deck which I'm fine with those
seats sure my dad's like you know Dwight
Gooden its seventh inning no hits my
dad's like this guy's pitching in no no
I can't be kept saying my Dwight's
pitching in no no he kept saying Dwight
guy's pitching [ __ ] no no and then so
and then so he's like we gotta get
better seats and I was again but it's
fine you know oh and by the way that day
what after I couldn't snow heater was a
Monday I had a science project due the
next morning the next day and my mother
had said my tol my father specifically
leave after the fourth inning he needs
to be home we have to gonna wake him up
at 7:00 a.m. he needs to finish this
science project the fourth inning Tony
I'm serious now keep my it's 1996 no
cell phones my mother's like yeah my
dad's at yeah the fourth inning I got it
don't worry baby call my mom babe still
like did been divorced 30 years but he
still calls her babe she's like this is
offensive so so he's like no problem
babe I'll have him back so it's you know
we're gonna cook dinner she's like we've
been divorced for 20 years you know he
just doesn't get it he still thinks her
happily married I'm like you live in a
bathtub so so he goes so my dad so we're
at the Yankee game now it's the seventh
inning it's [ __ ] way past the fourth
inning it's I see the time like dad mom
said to go home because listen it
Dwight's bitching - no no
so she'll understand no no yeah yeah
sure she'll understand she doesn't know
what baseball even is she's gonna know
what a no-no is so my mom so my dad goes
all right listen he goes it's coming up
on the eighth inning he goes we got to
get you behind home plate I gotta get
you behind home plate I said I yep but
Dad I don't care goes now he's pitching
in no no we're gonna go because you
gotta listen to me do everything I tell
you to do this is all [ __ ] like in
slow motion every
this day in my life so we get down to
the security guard behind home plate and
my dad sees two or three open seats
right behind home plate right in the old
Yankee Stadium and he says to the
security guard he's like I he goes
listening goes uh it goes you know it's
Dwight's pitch and no no he goes me my
kid
I mean first time I ever taken the
Yankee Stadium that was like my 12th
game that season he's like the first
time I've ever taken on his [ __ ] two
gang statements a big mom for my kid
Dwight's bitchin oh there's two seats
come on let me just you know take it out
cash my dad takes out cash what do I
need
you know greasing people and the guy
goes no he's not he can't sit down there
I'm sorry gonna have to watch him here
no man that takes your breath he goes he
goes alright he goes up but my son's got
special needs I was like what like
special needs and then I was just
sitting on with my mouth open like kind
of like with a half smile and then a
security guard gives me a noogie girls
have a good time kid
Jamie a complex because I'm like I know
I have like a weird mushroom haircut
super cut I don't think I look like I
[ __ ] have a special needs but I swear
to god this is where the story gets
unbelievable but I swear to god this is
[ __ ] true the row in front of where
me and my dad are saying now it's a
ninth-inning
Dwight's two outs away from the
no-hitter which he eventually yeah big
deal he see I see I notice it's [ __ ]
I'm 12 years old
height of the double-double you have big
wrestling fan mr. perfect who is that
one row in front of us mr. [ __ ]
perfect the wrestler every kid's
favorite wrestler at that time I'm like
dad that's mr. perfect and he goes who's
that and I go I go he's a wrestler and
he goes yeah I call I was [ __ ] great
and he goes and he just trusts Jelena he
drops the mystery goes yo perfect
perfect he goes give my son an autograph
what about getting my kid and watercraft
likes but you did no no and then mr.
perfect I swear God turns around he goes
no I swear to god he goes no like he was
just and here everyone is drinking and
you know whatever my dad does my son's
got special needs
still to this day Yankees tickets I'd
have a spy mr. perfect and then we get
back and it was the same story of my
father as it [ __ ] always is we're a
block away from mother's house two
o'clock in the [ __ ] morning down by
8:00
it's two o'clock in the morning my dad
goes don't tell your mother what
happened just don't tell your mother
what happened tell there was a train
delay a [ __ ] trailer so literally I
love your father do we rent a great
[ __ ] dad yeah we bring with it great
that right that and then my dad is so
funny cuz it's 2:00 a.m. and my dad used
to sleep in the basement cuz he had to
go all the way back to Staten Island and
then was 2 o'clock in the morning and my
dad starts walking in to go to the
basement and my mother goes Tony get the
[ __ ] out to take the ferry and three
trains all the way back to it's how
special being special and then and then
yeah and then I think I failed I didn't
you know I got a D on that science
project cuz I just cleaned it worth it
worth it what's new quarantine I'm
cooped up Chrissy kind of just having it
up for this [ __ ] already hey can you
still order delicious New York food or
are they shut down - no absolutely can
order you could order [ __ ] order
delicious food you know and then I they
just can't come within six feet of your
door so I got like a little rake hook
and then they call me on outside and
then come to put the put the food on the
rake and then I take it in and then if
they give me any lip I [ __ ] take
their legs out with the rake and get the
[ __ ] off my property that's crazy
great Opie from Opie and Anthony shell
and um sherrod had given Opie edibles in
a chocolate bar right and I didn't I
never taken Edel's before I'm not a drug
I don't know Opie just gives me the
chocolate bar I really supposed to take
half of a half of the square of the
chocolate bar okay so oh I'm and I love
sweets I mean I got high cologne you
know Michael's 250 up in have sweet tea
so I love sweets you know so I literally
oh we're on the train going to the
Islanders game New York Islanders game
and Opie just gives me the chocolate bar
and just starts looking at his phone so
I didn't know you supposed to take half
of half of square I ate the entire choc
just to the head Shiraz balls need a
kitchen Charlotte oh my god okay I
forget that it even happened because OB
just forgot me was like not doing the
weed so hoping you just gave me the
chalk bar didn't even think about it I
just [ __ ] crush this thing right
having a good time
all of a sudden right the Islanders game
first period buzzer goes off man I
thought somebody threw a spear from the
top of the jumbotron under my right
through the right side of my head
cutting off the left side of my body I
pop up at his seat I go I'm having a
stroke I'm having strong so I'm yelling
and I'm having a stroke right I forgot
that I was even on edibles I'm convinced
I'm having a [ __ ] job yeah so I go up
the stairs and I'm just walking around
like I'm having a stroke Opie I'm having
a stroke he's like you're not having
stroke I'm like dude I'm having a
[ __ ] stroke I'm at the left side of
my arm it doesn't work and I'm like
flinging my arm and it's not working so
then I'm like I have to so terrifying
dude so I'm in a packed Islanders game
and this is New York City I'm an big
andhe's fan oh he's a big Islanders fan
so people know who we are of course they
know Opie and they're like so they'll
stop at COP they're like oh they Eve
that guy's always on the show so they're
talking to me and I'm trying to have
these dude the actual just as luck would
have it the Islanders broadcast team
interviewed at opium brought me on the
intercom yeah and I cursed on [ __ ] SN
why would you say I yelled [ __ ] the
Rangers because they're playing you know
camera down see ya you know so I
literally I had gotten tickets I had
gotten tickets from the Islanders the
ticket Kinect was mine from the
Islanders so they found out that I
yelled [ __ ] the Rangers lose the tickets
I leave I leave Barclays Center like
walk up to a police officer who's in
full SWAT riot gear because I mean it's
New York City
these guys have real jobs to do this
terrorist activity I woke up to him I
said officer I'm gonna be 100% honest
truth right with right now
Ivan jested drugs and he goes up he goes
and he goes what do you mean he goes up
I said I said I'm having a stroke he
goes and he goes okay what kind of drugs
did you ingest I said I can't tell you
the type of marijuana strain that I've
ingest it consumed an illegal amount of
drugs I was try to use all these
professional words dude he started
laughing at me so
I thought he's gonna shoot his gun in
the because kid you have to [ __ ] out of
here movie and I was like you know so he
goes hey get the [ __ ] out of here so I
get in a cab it's on 4th Avenue and 8th
Street I get in a cab
I'm like take me to where I live 4th
Avenue and 93rd Street so the by the way
it was so I it was freezing it was
January but I had my Jaclyn I was so
[ __ ] hot I asked his cab driver to
open up all the windows this guy open up
all the windows and he was like
shivering and freezing I was like guy
I'm sorry I'm having fun - stroke right
now I'm on drugs you got to keep these
windows down and he was like I'm so cold
I'm so cold I was like if you could show
me a value as passport I'll put the
windows up I said they're staying down
literally dude it's 43 the cab drivers
stopped at a light at 4 - Evan 163rd
Street I looked out I'm like I'm home I
open the door I open the door and he's
like I thought I was on 93rd she put the
six and the nine were you know reversed
in my head bro I'm [ __ ] sweating it's
like eight degrees out I throw my jacket
like a $400 North Face jacket in a
public garbage pan in New York City back
right in Sunset Park Brooklyn I start
sprinting home I don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening I didn't live with my
kids mom at the time I go to my kids
mom's house it's 10 o'clock at night I
ring the bell home do it I ring the bell
she goes what are you doing here I was
like I'm having a stroke and she was
like Kris you're not having a stroke I
said I'm having stroke I've been jested
I've ingest it drugs so she goes oh my
god she goes alright come in so she goes
you have to take a shower she knew she's
to use drugs and she was a kid it's like
you have to take a shower
she's like I'll shower and I know I know
she was take a shower love you dad yeah
so I take a shower I take a show yeah I
[ __ ] start drinking this milk and
then I take a shower I take a shower
with my shoes and socks on so that means
I got completely butt-naked
I put my socks on my shoes back on I
step in her shower I haven't heard this
story I haven't heard like like a black
eye at this point exactly exactly yeah I
gotta get the grip totally taking a
shower with my [ __ ] shoes and socks
on and then it's like I'm
it's getting bad and then out of nowhere
just bang I start hysterical laughing
yes hysterical laughing having the
[ __ ] best time and then it was going
back in waves hysterical laughing
terrified hysterical laughing terrified
I slept on the floor in my at that time
two year old daughter's room all true I
sleep on the floor with her hurt she's
got a stuffed animal piggy she [ __ ]
loves its animal
I at some point in the night I take
piggy off her bed sleeping on the floor
I wake up Piggy's mouth on my taint
literally and I was sleeping butt naked
on my dark my two-year-old daughter's
bed in front of me but [ __ ] to think
about what she has to wake up to yeah
three years old her father who does live
in the house anymore is naked with her
favorite stuffed animal even her dad's
ass my balls an [ __ ] and then I woke
up you know my kid's mom like woke me up
and she saw what was happening because
she was the one who woke me up she was
like Chris you get out and then and then
like she sees the whole thing and she's
like this is why we can't be together do
it that's the worst
do it edibles yeah absolutely I mean I'm
staring right at [ __ ] right at
Brendan's and he's got nice tight jeans
on and he's got just nice [ __ ] thigh
lips well you know what it is dude he's
behind he bikes he's a serious mountain
biker now he bikes home yeah and Brian
you look like a space cat I like you I'm
leaning I'm leaning up and I've been
working out I appreciate that pal you
said honey bubbles no no don't call me
that
man I'm not comfortable with honey
bubbles now what about tortellini Toshi
like that I don't like tortellini for
cheating that's two no no I don't like
these things you have to call me Brian
why do I like you got a nice little
shaped head I mean you're [ __ ] you
look good baby got a nice little pump
yeah I got a pump I do all right I mean
I trained I trained I know days off you
know what I'm saying no dude yeah
absolutely so what what you say chicken
no you can't call you chicken tonight
you're objectifying man and it's right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[ __ ]